what makes a woman high value maybe
let's let's start with that like what
makes a woman valuable to a guy
I can't say as a guy I've dated women
I'm not sure if that is helpful but
let's talk about Mac so let's see if you
guys have
um have some advice have some insight on
what you think
uh makes a woman high value to a guy
like why should a guy choose you over
the other four billion women sort of
thing
[Music]
um so yeah so what makes a guy or sorry
a woman high value to a guy like you
know what does she need to bring to you
know to the table that's a really good
question
um I definitely think a woman needs to
be able to respect not only her
boundaries but her partner's boundaries
and if that is you know taking down
provocative photos then that makes the
woman high value if she does take down
those photos if she does respect his
boundaries in order to stay in the
relationship then that is a high value
woman somebody that doesn't choose her
friends over her partner is a high value
woman somebody that chooses her partner
first rather than her guy friends is a
high value woman
using
um definitely you know choosing that
relationship over validation is also
very very important so this is something
that you've always believed or is this a
recent
ly yes absolutely where does this come
from like where did you learn this
big man upstairs
all comes from religion culture family
absolutely okay yes Alexandra so what
makes a woman high value
I think every I think everything that
that Sophie said Is Right On Target and
I think a high value woman is confident
like there's this music video out there
um to where I can't remember it off the
top of my head it's horrible with recall
and but she walks into a room and all
eyes are on her and
the music video is just
that's a high value woman it's just her
essence
is what makes a woman high value or her
costume music video
Imma have to go back and look at it and
I'll get back to you on it but that
woman's Essence it just
it rocks you to your core and it really
makes you feel like that's what I want
to be that's what I want to achieve it's
not you know what you bring to the table
every single time it's who you are at
your core and what characteristics and
values that you have and the discipline
that you have because when you walk into
a room you're either you know bringing
the confidence of who you are and what
you represent or you're just going to be
in the corner and blend in with
everybody else so to for me a high value
woman is somebody that that stands out
commands a room
um but also has the soft sensitive side
and that's one thing that that I'm
really learning is it's not always about
being the strong independent woman the
woman that you asked what she brings to
the table and she starts listing all her
accolades all her accomplishments
um that's only going to get you so far
you think men are concerned with women's
accolades accomplishments degrees
I think that there's a pool of men that
may be intimidated by that but then
those are just betas in my opinion and
the alphas go after the woman that can
hold her own that can hold up the
kingdom while he may have to step away
they can run his own business you know
and knows his business like the back of
her hand and it's it's like the whole
wolf mentality for the lion however you
put it I guess question for for all the
ladies is can a woman be an alpha
absolutely not absolutely not
no that's a man's job man is supposed to
be the alpha that's
her job I guess what defines Alpha well
you've got to think about it if you're
walking down the street are you combat
ready you're gonna fight next to your
man no you're gonna run he's gonna fight
you're gonna run
that's enough
we our our job as women is to be
emotionally available for our men to
obviously you know help them emotionally
and to help them you know have somebody
to be there for them to listen men are
supposed to fight that's
that's kind of like okay job so when it
comes to anything
masculine I would say um when it comes
like if somebody were to break into my
my home right
and I'm with my husband or my boyfriend
or whatever it is
he would have to take on that person
that Intruder that's his job that's not
my job
yeah I bought the alpha in that moment
so you gotta think about that guys come
on Alexandra Ashley
I mean you you hit it on the head you
said in that moment yeah so life is just
accumulation of moments of what moments
are important to you I think if you're
with the right man you can really
flourish in your feminine energy but I
think
at the beginning you have to protect
that feminine energy and sometimes it is
with the masculine energy if I would
have had the feminine energy of putting
all my eggs into my ex's basket because
emotionally I needed to be there for him
and I'm gonna wholeheartedly support you
and not watch out for myself well I
wouldn't have bought my own house and
started my own career and done all of
those things so
in some cases you have to be that Alpha
within yourself but don't go head to
head with your own husband
you're it's you and your husband against
the problem not you and your husband
against each other yeah interesting
Ashley
um I don't know what
full definition for an alpha is like
what qualifies as an alpha well I don't
I don't think I would explain it you
know more so from the sense of your
perspective of understanding and your
scope of of like you know exposure to it
is can uh can a can a woman be an alpha
you know you've probably heard the term
alpha female right
no no you don't think so oh I haven't
heard that term so I I don't I feel like
I wouldn't be able to answer probably
because you know
a woman can be an alpha on her own but
if she's in a relationship she's not the
alpha that's just
online Okay
I want to hear from you on this you know
can a can a woman can a female be an
alpha yeah
absolutely
um I mean okay so
I would consider myself pretty Alpha
pretty Dom honestly and I would be
looking for someone who again is very
similar so I don't have a problem with
being an alpha with another Alpha and us
taking on the world or whatever life
together
um
uh so I mean I would yeah okay but how
would that work in in terms of a
relationship I mean if you have two how
can two people lead a relationship I
mean how how would that manifest itself
so I said earlier that I want someone
who also still has their own life and I
have my own life but we enjoy being with
each other so I'm not looking for
someone to lead my life for me
um I have a pretty full life to where I
enjoy everything that I do and I want
someone else who also has a pretty full
life and they enjoy what they do so I
don't want someone who's gonna like try
and tell me how their relationship's
gonna be
you know what I mean right but within a
relationship there are decisions that
are made that affect the relationship
whether that's going on trips or let's
say you ever got married again and it's
you want to have kids you need to figure
out what state you're going to live in
or what school you're going to send them
to or who's going to work or who's gonna
who's gonna make the majority of the
money or who's gonna how you're gonna
pay bills like all of those things come
into play in relationship right there
are things you have to talk about
together so how do those decisions
ultimately get made if if there's a 50
split as far as responsibility and
decision making goes and you have two
opposing ends of the decision-making
process you want to do a and he wants to
do B how do you ultimately come to a
decision on what to do
like if it was a trip and I wanted to go
somewhere and he didn't he doesn't have
to go that would be more money spent on
him going anyways and vice versa if he
wants to go somewhere I mean shoot go
let go I'm fine here I'm very happy here
I'll just continue what I'm doing here
and then he can go when it comes to
buying a house and someone doesn't like
the house we're not going to get the
house right so if it comes to like a car
someone doesn't like the car let's
figure out something else
but you can have some sort of authority
over making decisions though when it
comes to like certain decisions when it
comes to like your safety or your
well-being like you said you know house
or whatever like what school the kids
are going to go to but when it comes
down to like your well-being and your
safety do you think men should have that
authority over the decision that they
make your your decision I feel like they
should my safety yeah like let's say
you're going down two paths and you want
to go down this path but your boyfriend
or your husband wants to go down this
path even though it's longer and he
wants to take this one because he knows
it's safer are you going to listen to
him or are you going to go down your own
path
I'm not a dummy who would go down the
wrong path like a bad path and I'm
probably a better shot than most guys
that I know with a gun so I'm not too
worried about a man making my decisions
but if you're in a relationship with him
let's say it's not just like some random
guy but if it's like a guy you're in a
relationship with and you trust him and
you've built this emotional you know
connection with him and everything like
that and then he's like hey you know
what I think this is a safer route and
we're gonna go down this route okay
we're gonna we're gonna go down this
path and you're like no but I think this
path is better I'm gonna go down this
path and you go down that path and you
get killed you should have listened it
you know because Authority you know what
I mean it's like he has because why
would he know better than me unless like
I come from a relationship where I made
all the decisions yeah
what hold on that was your marriage
where you made all the decisions yep do
you say like did that
do you find it attractive in the
relationship when you're making all the
decisions when you have to make the
calls or do you or do you have an
expectation that he's to make some
I'm a pretty smart woman I like all the
decisions that I made even in our
marriage
um and it got me where I am today and I
really love where I'm at today so I
wouldn't do anything differently
hmm
do you I mean I don't buy it
I don't buy it I mean I'll just say it
um
so so the so the question I got for you
Kayla is um if you were to describe the
top
let's say the top five traits of your
ideal man like what would they be like
are we talking about looks or like
characteristics both
um or you know you can do five of each
you know if you want to do five looks
five characteristics whatever but just
give me the top top traits you would
look for in your ideal
partner uh good communication skills
emotional charity
those are three I guess characteristics
they're on my hinge
um
oh well into his career we already
discussed that established yeah
huh established in a career yeah yeah
established and uh
just like a
good personality like a good person gets
along well with others
not someone who's trying to make
decisions for other people you know like
one of my deal breakers is someone who
has like very strict political views is
because it just constantly feels like
they're bringing those up about what
other people should be doing whereas
like we're all here and I kind of feel
like everybody's going to answer for
their own things at the end of the day
do you have political views or you just
like
blanket across the board
way happier with life not being
concerned about other people's lives
I've got enough they're not enforcing
their political views on you if I
understand you correctly right yes
correct yeah right I really hope you
guys enjoyed that clip if you want to
watch the full-length podcast you can
find that over here that clips from if
you're new to the channel make sure you
hit subscribe over here and pin down
below in the top comment you'll find a
bunch of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out